make a table and solve a biologist is
researching the impact of three
different water based sugar drinks on
bees ability to make honey he takes two
liters of drink a so he takes two liters
of drinking which contains 40% sugar so
let me write this down let me make our
table and then we can solve it so let's
take a Mount amount amount of drink
amount of drink and then we'll say
percent sugar percent sugar and then we
can say sugar quantity so the actual
physical quantity of sugar so sugar
sugar maybe I should say sugar amount or
amount of sugar amount of sugar now this
first drink drink a he says he takes two
liters of drink a which contains 40
percent sugar so this is drinks let me
write the first column will be which
drink we're talking about so drink a he
takes two liters of it so it's two
liters two liters of drink a it's forty
percent sugar
forty percent so if we want the actual
amount of sugar and liters we just
multiply two liters times forty percent
or times 0.4 so you say two times let me
write times as a dot so you don't think
it's an x2 times 0.4 which is equal to
0.8 liters of sugar so you have 0.8
litres of sugar one point two liters if
I guess the other stuff in there is
water but it's point eight out of the
two liters is sugar which is forty
percent now he adds one point two liters
of drink B he adds one point two liters
of drink B so drink B he adds one point
two liters of drink B he finds that B's
prefer this new solution drink C so when
you add these two together you end up
with drink see you end up with drink C
and we end up with how much of drink C 2
plus one point 2 is 3 point 2 liters of
drink C which has 25
percent sugar content so this is 25
percent 25 percent sugar which also says
we know the amount of sugar in it
because if we have 3.2 liters of it and
it's 25% sugar or if it's 1/4 sugar that
means that we have point 8 liters of
sugar here so this is 0.8 liters of
sugar of sugar well that I already wrote
in the column name that's the amount of
sugar it's 25% sugar we have 3.2 liters
of it now they want to know what is the
percentage of sugar in drink B so let's
just call that X so the percentage of
sugar and drink B let's just call that X
so that's right over here now if it's X
percent sugar here and or this is the
decimal equivalent that's X how much
sugar do we have we have 1.2 liters
times the decimal equivalent of sugar so
this is going to be 1.2 times x 1.2
times X now let's think about it we have
point 8 liters of drink of sugar and
drink a and when you add it when you add
this amount to it you still have point 8
liters of actual sugar and drink C so
this thing has to be equal to zero I
mean we could set up an equation here we
could write we could write zero point
eight plus plus one point two x is equal
to is equal to zero point eight you
subtract zero point eight from both
sides you get one point two X is equal
to zero X has got to be equal to zero so
this thing right here has got to be zero
there's no sugar in drink B it's just
got to be like one point two liters I
guess the the solution is in water so
it's one point two liters of water
there's no sugar in drink B it is zero
percent sugar